welcome to this video playing Lauren
swept let's see you know it's about the
I said I think a British player living
in Germany's John Fleck Oh
Ponciano you don't see that too often
Queenie for yeah this is actually a way
to make this opening playable some
people still try to play Bishop b5 which
is entirely incorrect
Queenie forever is a playable option
however I'm simply forgetting how it is
played 97 nothing for black I really
have forgotten most most that I have
ever known of this opening ok can I not
just play a 60 mm wonders no it's 97
really correct don't know ok I mean I
can I can play em play a 6 anyway for a
fine position but I wonder if there's
something else
nobody should d7 maybe
maybe this is even a bit more bit more
ambitious
didn't think about that move at all yes
what's this what if I take on d4
actually if this entirely ridiculous
maybe it is 94 Bishop g5 94558 NT is
getting b7 at the end of all that okay
okay let's just do that keeping it
simple
yeah one one of the very little goals of
this opening is to get the other person
to to use time remembering what to play
or choosing from many good options and
this happened I've got I burned two
minutes for not much I mean black is
already I think very comfortable I
threatened 1994 yeah I can take one Jim
should I take then yeah more than long
castle you have to G form crash arising
a deform
yeah this should be quite okay for me
maybe I'm threatening to take F 3 and D
for already gaining upon but not 100%
sold on that maybe it is just working I
thought that this was strange actually
it's very much weakens the dark squares
question is now taking yeah let's do
that it's it's a simple approach and
then get onto the dark squares I have a
great night only 5 yeah
Bishop c5 what does he playing after
that
yeah probably this one not not exactly a
move you love to play young you love to
play maybe just go ahead with F form
okay so where do I go now to d7 twelve
six that's right
taking on d5
pressure only three now so should not
just 94 anise let's keep it to keep it
simple keeping the time situation in
mind
I'm just trying to keep pressure without
doing anything too fancy
just take am night 84 I can capture play
queen bee form check
yeah g6 yes just just keep everything
control control what if I take a form
yeah he's got his going going to the
seventh I just I just can for taking now
rook f6 and there isn't really no reason
not to take it and that's not necessary
strictly a rupee eight or something is
also fine but he might resign yeah yes
no move King rook f6 I just flaking e7
and there's nothing going on
yes you probably gathered I really have
a very low opinion about this opening
and I'm still amazed that Magnus Carlsen
plated last year
Tata Steel unfortunately his opponent
women war champion who he fun
she played Knight f6 in this position
and not one long right who you found
play this is wide against Magnus he
played it against Hari Krishna I'm sorry
but harikrishna played I think Knight f6
and not d5 and would have been very
interesting to see what what Magnus's
idea was to be honest I think the only
really a good relatively good option if
a while is to play d3 and then drop it
back playing sort of a filly door with
white but this I think is already close
to too good for black you build up this
pseudo pressure but here I forgot about
you for actually now you build up this
pseudo pressure here in this with Queen
a 4b should be fired
at the end you will just lose the bishop
in the process or have some other
problems with that it's just not um just
not a particularly great opening and
yeah yeah I could play 94 but I thought
that it would not lead to so much check
this I had calculated but I wasn't I
wasn't entirely sure what's going on
here now it's probably quite good yeah
yeah that's quite good
okay so we got to this position which
seemed okay a D 5 D 5 a think just a
mistake
after that I'm having such a good
strategical advantage with this week on
he has almost see 6 is also a good move
yeah I didn't see that just directly
gaining the pawn that's even stronger
than my f5 now this is also very good
but c6 was immediately killing hmm all
right thanks for watching